所以他這樣講之後今天怎麼樣
今天整個大盤就
整個AI
暴動
這不是被動 是暴動
而且今天以這個台積電的子弟兵
創意率先 創新高
而且最近投行李一直在買
所以他今天是
應該講今天是重中之重
沒有什麼問題
第二是聯電
聯電是今天漲得比台電還要多
而且這一波 頭信也大買
結果我們看到產物設備的裡面
材料的中砂也亮燈
然後散熱的高麗跟雙紅也紛紛亮燈
那這個部分可能大家比較關心台達
不過台達還在緩步的
在慢慢的墊底的這個部分
所以我們等一下再來看
好 那我們來看
我們之前有講過雙紅
雙紅 我說頭信還沒領情
外資已經開始買了
後來頭信就開始回來買
那股價怎樣也就拉上去了
這是周形態喔
周形態是已經過了前面的高點的位置而且它距離前高一步之遙所以它今天有點稍微尾盤有點稍微被壓一下但是我覺得看起來還會繼續往上走那你看到買賣超的部分是一萬七千多張對三千九百多張
所以看起來還是一個買方的趨勢
沒有什麼改變
但是它在漲的時候
它就會把齊鴻
建設這個族群通通都帶上來
因為他們算是一個整個族群的股票
它不會是單一檔
中沙比較尷尬
比較尷尬 因為它是金貝
金貝供電裡面除了它以外
還有另外一種就是8028
森陽辦也有這一塊
可是森陽辦比較多是再生金源
所以它就會受到再生金源
這塊的市場的影響
所以它相對來講
可能就沒有表現那麼漂亮
你看這是中砂的部分
基本上投心也是大買
投心也是大買
而且你看這是州的型態
州的大量高就在這裡
之前拉回來整理完之後
就噴出去了
而且今天是爆大量
符合總統講的
總統講的
這個大量要小心一點
當然要小心一點
今天反而是要比較小心
對 因為報大量
其實投資沒有買那麼多
我投資沒有買
而且外資金是稍微減碼的方向
所以創高後反而我們要注意一下
對 所以不見得是
創高就一定要去追啦